I asked you a question
so here come the Java stuff do you guys
have each other's hey do you guys have
each other's code to your phones do you
have each other's codes to the phone
oh you just know my code
what the [__] is wrong
see the shitty grips
that was you okay so the rule is you
have her code she can't have your code
I like that
is that the rule like if she wanted to
code to your phone would you give it to
her you're like nah you got
what's wrong
you keep laughing that's wrong with God
because he know what he's trying to do
right now what am I doing I'm just
asking
questions
that's gonna change your code at any
time right like my coat today might not
be my code tomorrow because I'm a high
profile rapper and I need to make sure
my Security's on point
oh [__] I took out no I just no that's
what it is I just don't agree with it
then why are you in my phone then
like I told you earlier it's only I only
get one I only get one [__] to care
about that I sleep with every night hey
you care if you feel me almost call me
head again
you got one right yeah my wife yeah I'm
married yes
hey you're not married and you sure
you're gonna be hard on it right yeah
that's just that weird [__] you good
that's unfair